so AOC went down to the border and and
and to check out the detainment
facilities down there and what do you
know she makes some dramatic and
horrifying discoveries I mean it's it's
almost like it's scripted or something
she says that conditions are terrible of
course that that border agents are
abusive but that's not all she claims
that the detained women are forced to
drink out of the toilet okay so here's
the report from The Daily wire it says
kzo quartz has repeatedly claimed
without evidence that CBP officials told
detained female migrants to drink from
the toilet while occasional Cortes was
present then when pressed by a reporter
if she actually heard of CBP officials
say that occasionally Cortez refused to
answer multiple CBP officials who spoke
on the condition of the anonymity told
the Washington Examiner and the Daily
Mail how Kaiser Cortez acted inside the
facility and say that she distorted the
entire situation a border agent who was
there told the examiner so this is what
happened with the migrant and drinking
water from the toilet she wanted water
didn't know how to use the faucet in the
cell and drank from the toilet she never
told AOC that we made her drink from the
toilet
AOC of course changed it this was when
she the migrant was apprehended and
brought into the facility an editor for
The Daily Mail David martes Co tweeted
out a photo from inside a CB t CBP
detention that showed a toilet that was
connected to a sink that states potable
water so these are a standard issue
apparently in in jails across the
country they've got the sink attached to
the toilet but that doesn't mean you're
literally drinking out of the toilet a
witness who was at the facility
described a Kaiser Cortes his behavior
towards CBP officials as being
threatening saying that she was crying
and screaming and yelling I it's not
funny I mean it well it is funny
actually because I can just imagine that
you know a Oh AOC is down there just
being utterly hysterical
just okay a second CBP official
described one of acacia Cortez's
outburst telling the examiner the 29
year-old said said something under her
breath oh all these guys in here are
gonna f me that's apparently what she
said according to this CBP officials the
agents are standing there behind the
computers the official continued one of
the agents laughed at something he was
saying to another agent and she got a
rate and flipped out now they're under
investigation she took it as they were
laughing at her and screams at them and
says what's so funny okay so so that's
what it sounds like quite a scene down
there and quite a scene down there
mainly on the part of a case of cortez
who is making a scene and we know that
she has a flair for the dramatic because
think back to those photos she went down
when she was looking at a and pretended
to cry for the cameras so this is
someone who's a very dramatic and
theatrical hysterical and she's bringing
that with her into a situation where
that's kind of the last thing you need
look I'm perfectly willing to believe
that the conditions in these facilities
could stand to be improved and I
certainly believe that we should treat
all people in our custody with with no
matter why they're in our custody if
they're in our custody they should be
treated with humanity and dignity I
don't think anyone really disagrees with
that I think almost everybody is on
board with that but AOC is a terrible
spokesperson for this issue she's
terrible because as I said she's German
she's hysterical and dramatic and I'm
sure I'll be called sexist for claiming
that a woman is being hysterical but
look not all women are her stearic are
are hysterical but AOC is a hysterical
woman that's just that's just I mean
look if you don't wanna be called
hysterical don't be hysterical also
she's hyper partisan so that makes her a
bad spokesperson for this issue and
she's already made her judgments before
going there she she called
concentration camps before she showed up
and toured the facility she'd already
said that so that meant that she had to
discover something that was going to
justify that comparison now even if they
weren't drinking at the toilet that
still wouldn't justify comparisons to
the to the to the Holocaust and
concentration camps but the fact is she
decided before she went that they were
concentration camps and there was zero
chance that she was gonna go and come
back and say you know what it could be
improved but it wasn't as bad as I
thought so
hey let's let's dial it down a few
notches there was zero chance that she
was gonna come back and say that she had
to find something and look at that she
did and the final thing that makes her a
bad spokesperson is that she's a liar
so I flat-out simply do not believe the
stuff about the toilet at least the idea
that the women were forced to drink out
of the toilet or tell ya you want water
you gotta get it from the toilet the
idea that we're having them drink out of
toilets I just don't believe it it's
simple as that it has kind of a hands up
don't shoot sort of vibe to it where it
fits with the established narrative to
perfectly it's too convenient for her
for AOC for the people that are
criticizing our immigration policies to
witness something like that is just too
convenient so I just don't believe it
but as I said can we improve the
conditions
I mean sure probably but even if the
conditions are not up to snuff that's
not necessarily because there's some
sort of conspiracy among Border Patrol
agents in fact I'm pretty sure there
isn't a conspiracy to treat these people
in humanely to treat them like animals
that's that's probably not
whatever improvements could be made with
the conditions the need for those
improvements has nothing to do with with
that it's it's that this is a
bureaucracy that these Border Patrol
agents they work for the government they
are at the mercy of the bureaucracy and
so if
not prepared with the right supplies and
everything else that's because they're
not they the Border Patrol ages aren't
being supplied with those to play are
being given those supplies and so like
with anything else if you're looking for
blame you got to look up the chain of
the bureaucracy because that's usually
where it where it lies
but two things to keep in mind here
number one improving the conditions of
the facilities is a practical issue it's
a practical problem to solve and it
requires a sober and reasonable approach
AOC is not a sober a reasonable person
she's down there screaming and crying
okay that's that's not what we need
there is a there is very little sobriety
or reasonableness when it with AOC or or
with respect to this issue at all or
with respect to any issue in this
country that's why nothing has ever
accomplished because everybody is just
looking to showboat or throw red meat
and very few people have the the just
rational calm approach to things that we
need and number the second thing to keep
in mind and I think we just should
continue emphasizing this is that you
can avoid ending up in these facilities
that's one of the reasons why the
concentration camp compared so well
there are many reasons why that
comparison is absurd one of the reasons
why it's absurd is that in Nazi Germany
if the Nazis wanted to send you at a
concentration camp you didn't have any
choice you couldn't just leave the
country in fact you could be in your own
country and the Nazis came in and
invaded your country and said you know
concentration camp right with this
though you could easily avoid ending up
in these facilities just don't sneak
across the border right if you don't do
that then you're not gonna be in the
facility now that doesn't just it
doesn't mean that we can treat them in
humanely it doesn't mean that the
conditions don't matter that's not the
point I'm making but there is speaking
of practical things here there's a
practical point where if you want to if
you want to avoid that you just not come
it's an easy way to avoid it don't sneak
across the border and you don't end up
there
so the problem is when you've got a
whole flood of people sneaking in that's
gonna put a strain on the system and now
we're scrambling to get all the supplies
and everything we need to take care of
this onslaught of people and that
creates a precarious situation if you
don't want to be in that precarious
situation then don't do that because
what we're not doing see we unlike the
Nazis
we are not invading Central America and
taking these people and dragging them
across the border and putting them in
you know locking them away that's that's
not they're coming here even despite
knowing maybe they're aware they know
about these facilities and the allegedly
bad conditions and they're still coming
so there's an easy way to avoid it okay
checking and briefly here because I
don't want to I don't want to just leave
this issue as we discussed yesterday the
domestic terror group and Tifa staged a
violent riot over the weekend where they
assaulted a journalist and they bash
people over the head with lead pipes and
crowbars and none of the presidential
candidates as of yesterday had said a
word about the incident none had
condemned antiva they all ignored it
what about today I think I want to check
in again and maybe I'll just keep
checking in every day to see if when
these Democrats want to get around to
saying hey by the way I am against
smashing people in the head with
crowbars
for political reasons or for any reason
so it's been three whole days have any
of them said anything well finally
Andrew yang did say something yesterday
he tweeted he said I hope and Ino is
okay journalists should be safe to
report on a protest without being
targeted okay that's that's fine I mean
that's not much of a that's not a very
passionate condemnation but it's better
than nothing as for the rest no Camille
Harris
nothing Joe Biden nothing Bernie Sanders
nothing
Gillibrand nothing mayor Pete nothing
O'Rourke
I mean go down the line the other 19 or
whatever candidates have said nothing on
this and that is I say again I mean as
cynical as I am the I am I guess more
naive than I thought because I figured
that they would most of them would at
least say something just probably kind
of half-hearted but I expected them to
at least say something yet they're not
and why is that it's important for us to
realize well I think there are two
reasons why the Democrats are ignoring
this number one they realize that their
base is extremely radical and that
antifa their base is basically comprised
of an Tifa members or antifa
sympathizers there are a lot of them on
the left and they know that which is why
they're not going to condemn antiva in a
primary they might do it in a general
now if this was a general election and
they know they have to appeal appeal to
more reasonable and saying people in the
middle then maybe they would condemn but
not in a primary they can't because
they've realized that their base this is
what they're into and I also think that
these people personally these Democrat
candidates many of them are just bad
people to put it bluntly and I think
that they wit they would love it if if
they could take a crowbar and smash the
heads of conservatives or their
political opponents whoever they were
they would love it if they could do that
but they can't so instead they just kind
of stand on the sidelines and smile
quietly while other people do it I think
that's part of the part of the reason
now maybe that's unfair maybe that's not
true but the thing is when you refuse to
condemn this kind of violence this kind
of behavior the rest of us are left only
to speculate as to the reasons why
you're silent and how you really feel
about it if you want to put those
thoughts to rest you want to put the
speculations to rest you could just come
out and say look I condemn this it's
horrible it's terrible and TiVo should
be shut down you can come if you're not
going to say that then all I can do is
speculate and these are my speculations
which I am which unfortunately I'm in a
position
after speculate like that okay moving
there's a lot of topics I want to hit so
we're moving kind of rapid-fire here
this is an issue that is just
tailor-made for speaking of read me this
is tailor-made for conservative talk
radio reading now from The Daily wire
report it says according to The Wall
Street Journal Nike was forced to pull
an American flag themed shoe called the
Betsy Ross from production after NFL
quarterback turned political activist
Colin Kaepernick who inked a
multi-million dollar dollar sponsorship
deal with Nike last year complained
Kaepernick were reportedly told the
company that he found the very idea of
the shoe offensive later odd says the
shoe shipped out to retailers this week
but Nike quickly recalled the shoe and
demanded retailers return their stock
leaving customers confused the shoe
isn't available for sale on the brand's
website in a statement from Nike said
only that the company decided against
releasing the sneaker because it
featured an old version of the American
flag let's see here
turns out Nike was responding to a
request from Kaepernick himself who saw
the shoe online and could play directly
to Nikes top brass The Wall Street
Journal says after images of the shoe
were posted online mr. Kaepernick and
Nike endorser reached out to the company
officials saying that he and others felt
the Betsy Ross flag is an offensive
symbol because of its connection to an
era of slavery some users on social
media responded to posts about the shoe
with similar concerns you know I'd never
got too bent out of shape about the
kneeling thing I was never really into
that whole controversy and I was very
happy when it basically ended not
because I was all that offended by the
kneeling but just I was so sick of the
topic and it went on for way too long so
I ever cared much about that
and as far as I'm concerned as I pointed
out many times
kneeling is a sign of respect kneeling
is a sign of submission and respect so
in fact if anything if you
in front of the flag you're being not
only being rep you're being too reverent
it's almost idol worship to kneel to the
flag right so now I know that they
didn't mean it that way that wasn't the
that wasn't the the message they were
trying to send but as far as I'm
concerned that that is what it means to
kneel in front of something and so if
they want to do that let him do it that
was my thought on this though is is just
this is something else that Nike would
bend to the demands of I first you have
Kaepernick being offended by actually
being offended by a flag because here's
the thing we were told
I know it's ancient history now but
thinking back to when that whole
controversy was having what what we were
told was that this protest was not
really about the flag they weren't
protesting the flag they weren't
disrespecting the flag itself right they
were it was about police brutality at
least originally and then it morphed
into who knows what it became this
ambiguous kind of thing really just a
trend but originally Kaepernick said
this is about police brutality
it's not about disrespecting the flag
it's just it's about sending a message
about this particular issue well
apparently it was about the flag the
whole time because here he is offended
by a flag this isn't about police
brutality this is just he isn't like the
flag he thinks the flag itself
represents slavery which means by the
way that the flag of almost every
country in the world any any country
that's been around for 200 or more years
by this logic all of their flags
represent slavery because they all had
slavery all of them if they've been
around that long so by that logic every
city flags you know most of the flags of
the country flags on earth are offensive
and represent slavery by that logic but
of course we only single out America for
this when talking about slavery we
single out America
somehow slavery is a unique American sin
even though as an institution that
lasted for thousands of years across the
entire world and that every race and
ethnicity and they all practice it right
be that as it may I think this this
finally reveals what most of us realized
all along that this really is an anti
American things is an anti flag thing
and finally Kaepernick is coming out and
admitting it okay before we get to
emails I wanted to mention one other
thing there's this is an issue that may
not be important to to you but it's
something that takes me off so I'm gonna
rant about it
for six hours there's this girl young
girl eight years old who you've probably
seen her online she's achieved some
measure of viral fame because of these
parody videos she does where she makes
fun of aoc her name the girl's name on
the internet now is mini AOC and these
videos are very popular conservatives
love them yesterday your Twitter account
posted these pictures look at these
mocking the staged photo op that aoc dad
did down on the border last year and
here's the tweet that they account sent
out with with the little girl pretending
to be OC now
I mocked those photos also they are
hilariously mockable and aoc herself it
provides constant fodder for parody and
mockery so I get it I get the humor but
I also have to tell you I really hate
this I hate this kind of thing so much I
really really hate it I hate when people
use their kids for this kind of thing
what's happening here is that this young
girl is being used by her mother for
money and attention that's what's
happening and I can't stress enough how
much I hate it even though most and I
made this point yesterday online and all
many conservatives lighten up it's great
it's it's great fun even though none of
them would be saying if this core if
this was a girl
same same situation but she's mocking
Trump then all those could see none of
them would be saying Oh lighten up it's
like they'd all be agreeing with me so
it's that the
everybody has these double standards now
we all know that we have them but I I
hate it no matter what the no matter the
politics no matter whose side it is it
doesn't matter I hate bringing kids into
this kind of thing
by the way if you go to mini a a C's
Twitter account there's information
right in the bio there to contact her
for bookings bookings bookings for what
you know I mean her mom is contracting
her out to go and I don't do what
exactly I'm not sure what to do this
eight-year-old girl's gonna do some
hilarious political stand-up comedy yeah
I'm sure that's gonna be great stuff
from from an eight-year-old but that's
what I'm talking about
it's all it's all great fun no she's
being used for for money and attention
and fame that's what's been happening
here let me tell you something about
little kids I have three of them
our oldest are only a couple of years
younger than this girl so I can speak
with some experience here I guarantee
you that no eight-year-old would ever
think of something like this themselves
never period no eight-year-old is
watching the news and saying hey mom
let's do a hilarious spoof of that
congresswoman from New York yeah I got
some ideas I've been workshopping
to do a satire video that's just not
happening period it's not happening so
the people saying oh it's all in good
fun
first of all how do you know that oh I
saw the video looks like she's having a
great time what because she's smiling in
a video I mean do you not understand how
the internet works by now everybody
looks happy on the internet and 90% of
them are depressed so you can't possibly
know that but also this was not her idea
it was her mom's idea
her mom decided to get her started at 8
years 8 years old in a career of as a
political satirist that's simply not a
hobby that an eight-year-old anywhere on
earth would decide on themselves so her
mom is coaching her through all this
giving her the lines I mean how many
takes do when she does one of those
videos or did how many takes do you
think it took how many times you they
don't do it this way do it that way with
her mom directing it
posing her and doing all this kind of
stuff and she's eight years she doesn't
even understand
she doesn't understand satire I mean
most most adults don't even get it you
think an eight-year-old does oh she's
real smart this girl look I'm sure she's
a smart girl but no eight-year-old is
smart enough to really understand how
parody and satire works okay they just
they don't have the mental capacity for
so she doesn't really understand what
she's doing she didn't choose to do it
or mom is forcing her to do it and so
that's why I hate it let kids be kids
let them do kids stuff doing doing viral
videos is not kids stuff doing political
satire is not kids stuff try to get
shares and likes and tweets and
everything that's not what that's you
know we have to condition kids to care
about that kind of crap kids naturally
at that age you know they want to go run
around outside they want to go I mean
whatever they want to do but their kids
it here's nothing
it's dangerous enough already to simply
post pictures of your kids online and
that's why I don't do it anymore because
when you post pictures of your kids
online you're putting them in front of
potentially millions of people and you
don't know any of those people there's
no real advantage to it for your kid
there's nothing positive can come of
that for your kid the most you're hoping
for is neutral is that nothing positive
or negative comes there's zero chance of
anything positive coming there is some
chance of something very negative coming
from it but then consider it's one thing
when you're putting pics of your kids
out there which I think as I said as is
probably not wise but if you're putting
their face and image out there all over
the place in a political context okay
well then you've just made your child a
target a target and a minimum of
bullying and harass her assman online if
you go and you read the comments under
any of these pictures or videos that she
does you're gonna find many hundreds of
vile trolls saying horrible things about
this
about this girl and her mother and their
family and everything you you're you're
exposing her to that that way you you
are throwing her into that pit and why
you have put her face out there in a
partisan political context in this
environment and you have therefore
guaranteed that at a minimum thousands
of people are going to post vile and
insulting comments about her and who
knows if something worse could happen
people are crazy especially these days I
mean we saw an T for smashing people
with crowbars people are nuts
it's just can anyone argue that this is
best for the girl that this is really
gonna help her that this is somehow
gonna enhance her life in any way yeah I
just you know I have I've been tempted a
few times that I'm doing this show
because I'm it's no secret I am at my
house not at the moment but usually I'm
at my house doing the show and a lot of
times my kids are home and I mean there
have been times when they've almost come
into the room a little stupid shooting
and a few a few times I've attempted to
call them over and have them you know
come on camera for a minute because it'd
be kind of funny and but then I I don't
because I as I said I don't really want
their face in picture out there but I
also because I I am a political person
that's how I'm known as a political
ideological person which is fine for me
I'm an adult and I chose I chose this
life right I chose to do this nobody
forced me into it but I know that people
are crazy as I said so if I start
associating you know I bring my kids
into it and they become associated with
me and their image is attached to me
well then there's it becomes a sort of
political thing and I just I would be
afraid for their safety I don't want to
do that I just don't want them to have
anything to do with this as much time as
I spend online and I see how vile and
disgusting and hateful people are how
unhinged they are it's just a cesspool
a toxic dump on the internet and the
last thing I want to do is expose my
kids to it much less throw them into it
it's the last thing I would ever do I
because I just want them to be kids I I
want them to run around outside and I
want them if they're gonna watch TV
watch you know some dumb cartoon you
know not the news that's why I feel I
guess given what I do for a living and
what I see every day on the Internet and
the kind of comments that I get and just
what I all of that what I'm exposed to
the idea of my kids getting even a piece
of that kind of attention just makes my
skin crawl and I would never want to
expose them to it you do this with your
kids you turn them into a little avatar
for your political views and you try to
turn them into a viral sensation
especially a political viral sensation
then you have just thrown them in it
you've exposed them to that and there's
just no good reason to do it there is no
good reason period no good reason so
please people stop all right Matt well
show at gmail.com Matt well show at
gmail.com is the email address this is
from Dustin says Matt watching one of
your older shows please for the love of
God never wear that pink and blue plaid
short sleeve shirt ever again it's the
ugliest thing I've ever seen well Dustin
you should know by now that the quickest
way to get me to do something is to tell
me not to do it because I am essentially
a toddler in that way you tell me not to
do and I'll do it so I now that I think
it's it's well known that I have the
emotional maturity of a toddler so I
have to assume that this was reverse
psychology on your part and you were you
actually you love this shirt and you
wanted to see me wear it again because
it brings so much joy to your life to
see this beautiful handsome dashing
shirt and so that's why I'm wearing it
for you because I know I know
what you yeah I know what your real
intentions were
by the way if you want to buy this shirt
well I'm not sure where you could buy it
I think my wife bought it for me my wife
buys all my clothes because again I am a
toddler from Nick this is from Nick says
hi Matt big fan of the show I really
like hearing your interpretations on
religious topics and I'd like your
opinion on this one you said on your
show recently that you were okay with
the change in the words of the Lord's
Prayer because since it's a translation
there's some wiggle room so to speak I
agree that from a literal standpoint in
our current language the Pope's change
could make sense that being said as a
member of the Greek Orthodox Church my
father and I speak Greek and I looked at
the literal original text of the Lord's
Prayer of Matthew and the literal
translation is significantly closer to
and lead us not into temptation than let
us not fall into temptation I
acknowledge that there are some reports
that the first version of the Gospel of
Matthew was written in Aramaic but since
no text was ever found the earliest
available translation is Greek and the
line in question literally translates to
and introduced us not into temptation
I have double-checked this with my
grandfather as well who was born in
Greece and also knows some ancient and
Byzantine Greece knowing this can you
still defend the Pope's decision also
how does him being infallible in matters
of Scripture work when it comes to
changing the words of Jesus himself
thanks for all you do on the big fan to
your last question no the Pope is not
infallible when it comes to translation
issues he could be wrong and that's what
this is so he could be wrong about a
translation and I take your point about
the literal translation and how it's
closer to lead us not then lead us then
let us not fall into but I still think
that the point the idea the point the
concept is that we're asking God to
protect us from temptation
we are not requesting that he refrain
from himself tempting us because that's
not what God does God is not the tempter
Satan is the tempter so I think the
change in the Lord's Prayer just
reflects
the point the concept the idea that
we're all that is contained in the
original prayer it reflects the point
that we're making when we pray that
prayer so that's why I think it's I'm
fine with the change because I my point
I don't think it is a change I think
it's that's what is that's what it means
that's what Jesus was conveying now I
understand that the Lord's Prayer was
passed on to us just in terms of in the
scripture just a couple of pages after
the scene where Jesus is in the desert
being tempted by Satan and the depending
on which gospel you're reading it
actually says that Jesus was led into
the desert or or even led into the
desert by the Holy Spirit to be tempted
and so some people point out that okay
well Jesus it says Jesus was just led to
temptation by the Holy Spirit and then a
few pages later he's giving us this
prayer where we say don't lead us into
temptation and so there's the but I
think that's a good a good arguments a
good point and I and I would take that
point as well but I still think that
Satan is even referred to in Scripture
as the tempter that's not how God is
referred to and so at the end of the day
the point is God is not is is we're
asking for God to protect us from
temptation when you just think about
when you feel tempted to do commit a sin
whatever the sin might be do you think
does it do you think that God is the one
time thing you
do you pray that God will stop tempting
you or do you pray that God will protect
you from this sin or or or remove this
temptation which isn't to say that he's
the one who placed it on your heart in
the first place but how do you think of
it I think we all think of it as no
we're asking God to remove this
temptation but we're not saying that God
is the one who placed on our heart to
begin with we don't in other words we're
not praying with putting putting the
Lord's Prayer aside for a second do you
when you feel tempted do you pray God
stop tempting me I don't think anyone
does because again that's not what God
that's not God's Oh mo so to speak all
right from Chris Jeff this from
Christian says hi Matt loved the show
with the assault on know and the various
videos you showed why is the government
not getting involved whether it's city
state or federal
I heard that particularly in Portland
that the police are not even engaging
but this is clearly not a peaceful
protest group since the law protects
peaceful assembly not violence why is
there such little action against them
that's for the same reason why there was
little action against BLM I got the anti
police riots that were going on in
cities across the country a few years
ago remember the the mayor of Baltimore
infamously said while her city was being
burned while while stores were being
looted cop cars were being set on fire
bricks were being thrown people were
being assaulted she got up and said
let's give them space to destroy direct
quote so it's the same reason and the
reason is it's always the same boring
reason which is it's ideological and
political the powers that be in these
towns are Liberal Democrats and so and
these antiva members are Liberal
Democrats that's the reason
okay one more question this is from
really cool guy that's I guess that's
his Christian name interesting that
hello dear and fair dictator Matt Walsh
this is 19 year old Chilean Chris again
I narrated my intellectual journey a
couple weeks ago I have a question about
pride that I can't seem to solve myself
you and plenty of conservatives oppose
gay pride because you say that people
didn't choose to be gay and therefore
it's stupid to be proud of being
homosexual so far I agree what seems to
trouble me a lot though is that you do
say that you should be proud of being
American yet most Americans don't choose
to be Americans but they're born into it
how is that not hypocrisy and what in
which reasons is it in which reasons is
it proud to be something not surely I
know there must be a reason in front of
my face but I really don't see it since
you wouldn't support that intellectual
inconsistency I am overwhelmed
even Michael Knowles says that pride is
the mother of all sin yet he repeatedly
says as well that he is loud proud about
being the best country in the world and
he's proud of being an American god
bless you and your family okay yeah it's
a good question remember what I said we
were talking about this pride thing and
one of the problems in American English
especially modern American English is
that there's sort of a it's the language
has become impoverished and
sometimes we only have one word when
really we should have about five or six
different words so we try to use one
word to and apply it to all these
different situations and and then it
becomes confusing a word like love for
instance I mean love the Greeks had four
words for love we just have the one and
so that makes it confusing sometimes I
think the same thing could be could be
the set about pride the way I look at it
is that our pride in being American is a
different sort of pride its pride kind
of in the same way that I might say I'm
proud of my children
we are taking pride not in ourselves or
our own
received good qualities but in the
accomplishments of others and I I think
this kind of pride it's really more like
gratitude love appreciation it is
acknowledging and finding joy in what
others are doing or have done proud of
being American I think is like that it's
it's not like I'm proud of myself for
being American now that would be absurd
because as you pointed out I didn't do
anything to become their American I was
just born here and and lucky for me so
when I say I'm proud of being American
that's not what I mean I mean that I'm
proud of all the people who established
this country fought for it protected it
I'm taking pride in the history the
heritage the tradition all of these
things which I am grateful to be a part
of and this kind of it's a humble pride
it's a pride of acknowledging what
others have done it's not about you it's
about others
it's a grateful pride but with sexuality
there is no history no heritage that
comes with your sexual orientation being
proud of it is is not only absurd but
it's completely self focused it's all
about you it's your sexuality and you're
proud of it and so that's the difference
and that's why we talk about pride as
the mother of sin we say that you know
the Bible warns against pride but the
Bible isn't saying oh you should never
tell your son and your daughter you're
proud of them of course you should say
that but those are different kinds of
different types of pride which is why I
would say maybe rather than saying I'm
proud of being an American maybe a
better word would be I'm grateful to be
an American I appreciate being an
American I love being an American I'm
humbled to be an American all of those
words work and maybe we should use those
words the stet to differentiate it from
the pride that you're talking about here
all right thanks for that though thanks
for all the questions thanks for
watching and listening
Godspeed because it's a day that ends in
Y socialist congresswoman Alexandria
Ocasio Cortez is spreading lies
specifically about our southern border
we will separate fact from fiction which
should leave AOC
uncharacteristically silent then andino
speaks out after his brutal beating at
the hands of an Tifa finally nike disses
the flag for the 4th of July so the
Governor of Arizona disses Nike check it
out on the Michael Knowles show